Roy woods hey buddy hello when I'm in
analyze pluralized your name yeah hi Roy
I know blessin how you doing man I ain't
get at the man I'm chillin you dude now
what did you just do you just did
another show yeah somebody else's shot I
don't know this building's amazing it is
right you just call you're talking you
don't know who it is gonna go in this
room and talk to this way person another
one sounds like a good place it really
is I can always tell the guest though
that impression I roll in by the way you
know information last week what I can
always tell the guests that after their
appearance like they come in they do the
show they've left and I go they still
don't know who we are they don't know
what that's not true sure that's not
true they take you on a maze of people
you don't know it's no different than
when you're on the road and you're in
some weird Midwestern town and there's
five radio stations in the are you gonna
go to Chuck and then you're gonna go to
Fred then you're gonna go across the
hall to Laura and then Tim's gonna
approve a courtship but he's gonna play
that back next Thursday after your show
yeah is there anything better than when
you get morning press and like we have
three and you're like I [ __ ] like
don't in the same building and we all
think little on the road finding out all
your press is in the same building
there's nothing better than that it's
not the breasts that I hate I love to
have the opportunity to promote whatever
they hear it's the ride from station to
station with the weird person that they
get to driving in rush hour traffic it's
always like a busboy or just somebody
lower level at the club whose job it's
just to drive you to everything in the
small talk is torture it's really
horrible I try not to engage and now is
it somebody who's like they're just the
bottom of the totem pole so that's their
job or is it somebody who wants to be
close to the business one of these
either/or and they both have their own
pluses and minuses because then you have
people just laying comedy questions on
you all day and it's it's cool if it's
an employee that like deep down wants to
tell you all of the dirt right the
comedy club now that oh yeah please yeah
talking about you love like the Minda
than my new [ __ ] gossip of the comedy
showed up coked out and exactly
ticket sales when they owned two clubs
and ones across this by the city how
there's no unless I know you I don't
want you to succeed right I want so if
you haven't met a comic and you're like
I didn't do well huh yeah nice guy the
only time a roof of comics I don't know
is reality television cuz that [ __ ] is
hard yes comedy like judged comedy like
it's an impossible scenario for anybody
to succeed in and it's not cool like
they there's a video circulating now of
Richard Pryor son getting booed at the
Mason Pryor yeah
inside come on the deck is stacked
against anybody
at the Apollo and it's like really even
prior son you guys aren't even gonna
give him we watched that and analyzed it
and I thought the mistake he made cuz I
can't [ __ ] on priors dad but I thought
the mistake he made was he like he it
was a little too much of a reminder
personality-wise I thought that he
shoulda livery and all of that the hand
up he even the hand motion I thought
like he should have been more if he I
think if he would have just came out and
acknowledged it and then kind of been a
little bit more himself and a little bit
more of his own person I think it would
have served him a little bit better you
know what comedy family has like
completely distinct different styles and
deliveries I would say the wings and the
rocks
if you've ever seen Tony in so long I
know he was different than Christmas
still is yeah Jordan is like stoner Loki
no energy like the complete opposite
like if you gave Chris Rock like a
downer and then he just stood still for
the entire set so it's it's it's hard
it's hard man it's hard to be from a
comedy family and no doesn't matter it
doesn't Damon son do it - it's all it -
but you're nothing like Damon singer but
Damon singers not out doing it as much
because he's got that lethal weapon he
always has a [ __ ] show Damon and the
Damon juniors gun yeah TV - Oh does he
he keeps a pilot at least the past five
or six years well Damon is amazing
because he won in the cellar and you
watch him it like one o'clock in the
morning
bombing but but it was because he was
literally just talking through divorce
so when he wasn't up there hitting a
homerun he was literally kind of create
an hour of material and he was willing
to go on and do that which I loved about
him so much is he didn't give a [ __ ] he
would go on and just try material he
would try it and and swing and miss and
then go back up the next night and try
it he really went in the club and
[ __ ] tries that's so damon wayans in
LA a couple years ago and he's doing
that and you could tell the moment that
he was like I [ __ ] this crowd he pulls
his phone out and calls an uber from the
stage just walking into a club that's
not a headline show that's just him no
it's awesome
I respect that a lot and Roy by the way
you're promoting this is not happening
Fridays at midnight on Comedy Central
Roy Wood jr. calm and that's starting
this Friday yeah well we're already
likes I think six episodes well you are
good man so it's it's been fun it's been
funded and you took over Ferrari Shaffir
and I are we had no bad feelings about
that can you explain how that happened
you so people know exactly what that was
first and foremost Mia are we good yeah
we're good I wouldn't have taken the job
if I hadn't talked to him I got the
offer from Comedy Central a week before
taping was supposed to start so that's
how y'all reno the [ __ ] so i'll call
Ari and we chopped it up for about an
hour and I think everybody knows what
the deal was as far as like everything
with his special and he's negotiating
other projects with the network they
couldn't come to an agreement on that so
Ari stepped away well excuse me they
made the decision to replace Ari and so
from that that came the call to me and I
go do you want to host this and I know I
wasn't their first choice let's be real
about that [ __ ] I'm not the first person
you think of when you think of
storytelling comedy the thing that saved
me though was that I had already been
developing a story to tell on the show
so
in terms of capability all of that stuff
I felt like re trusted me enough that he
was able to I won't say give his
blessing but at least not [ __ ] on what
was gay oh yeah and that's something
I'll always respect re for because at
the end of the day
Arya's pro comedian and this show
creates opportunities for comedians a
lot of whom who don't get a lot of time
on television to be seen and to share
their comedy with the world so at the
end of the day for me I took the job
number one cuz I have a kid and I
wouldn't have to have a college yeah
number two you want to be able to be a
conduit for trying to keep the show
alive because if they what if they did
it would know those what if something to
XYZ happen and the show gets cancelled
after this run cuz they were going to
shoot this season it's too much money
already invested so for me it was just a
matter of getting an offer from Comedy
Central calling Ari and going yo man
this is what are your feelings on this
and what tips can you give me and we had
a really solid man a man conversation
but at the end of the day I'm basically
asking a dude how to [ __ ] his wife like
that's basically like that show is Ari's
baby and he was me I would have given
you the wrong tips about it
look they love it when you say [ __ ] yes
which is wow that's right it wasn't a
baby yeah he created that show in the
clubs and does he still have a creative
like credit right yeah he's created by
EP getting a check from it but you know
in presence he's not there and that's
why on the very first episode the first
thing I did was pay respect sure cuz
this [ __ ] is like when they change our
lives on Fresh Prince you can do that
[ __ ] and not acknowledge it why they
change FF because the darts cannot be
supposedly was kind of off the chain on
set and was kind of acting a fool so
they fired it and then Brighton and the
light-skinned outfit they just brought
it and they just called her Aunt Viv
yeah they just really person yeah yeah
like no that's a different no it's not
that's not good I mean it didn't even
and they didn't even look similar they
weren't they didn't look the same
knowledge it at all no so what I can't
do as a black man is walk up on a show
that's been hosted for three seasons by
a white man right yeah everything's fine
right nothing there was no turmoil or
nothing at all you had to explain it no
I went onstage and explained it because
that
that show is a place for raw honesty
it's it's supposed to be the one place
on TV for comedy where no [ __ ]
exists yeah it's if nothing else we all
know what happens with Network sets when
you do a five-minute for late-night show
and a nip and tuck and they [ __ ] with
your material a change your truths and
make you say things that you don't say
you see there that show that Ari Shaffir
setup is supposed to be the one spot
where comedians have to be honest and I
would be doing the show a disservice if
I didn't walk onstage and at least go
hey all right
this is weird and then dive right into
that yeah so you know it is what it is
man and we still talking about see him
in the streets I dab them up it's not
beef sure slightly awkward yeah it's for
sure awkward but it's not like there
goes Dave got him they decided it wasn't
like you took his gig and and lobbied
for it what happens when a network does
I remember when we were doing tough
crowd and you know Colin they were not
gonna do it with Colin and they were
gonna do with Geraldo and I don't know
if it ever got was made why would that
why was it because Colin was just not
willing to play ball the way they wanted
him to and he was right whereas they
would say things like hey don't talk
about race because Chappelle does that
don't talk about politician we have Jon
Stewart for that you guys talk about pop
culture and so Colin if I [ __ ]
Tuttle's guys we're talking about
Britney Spears they'll kill me like he
just didn't want to do it I know what he
wanted to do he wanted to have his
opinions on things so it didn't work out
they were gonna give it to Greg it was
very very awkward because we already
knew they had already begun making
announcements before we taped the final
episode in 2004 it was such a shitty way
to do it and Greg felt better but Greg
had three kids you know and they just
loved her although ok so then as a comic
on the outside looking in who do you
choose in that Devoy in that one I was I
I wouldn't do the new version I said I
won't do the new version but it was
different to me because and I loved Greg
but I you know Colin it was his show and
we were all in the show to kind of
together so I just wouldn't have done it
was it just you that said you wouldn't
do it or did the I thought I don't
remember what Nick said you'd have to
ask Nick I think Heath Robinson said the
same thing and Patrice may have I don't
remember and Vause just goes where the
money is
Voss literally tried to have Colin
Houston after season
so he could do someone else to show more
often bosses Berman there were guys the
same ilk there were guys are the same
ilk but this is not happening when they
found out that Ari wasn't hosting they
won't tell me the names but there were
guys who decided that they didn't want
to tape out of respect to Ari much in
the same situation as you and not out of
disrespect yeah I know
I'm cool with them I have no enemies in
the standard world as far as I know it
might be somewhere [ __ ] I think I'm
not funny but that's different from
being in absolutely er so you know that
I get it so I'm on this side years of
this season I don't know what I'm on but
we tape I think Talib Kweli was on my
episode yeah but I forget who else was
on hope I didn't scrap that episode no
they did they will you know they shot 20
so they're doing 10 this run and then I
think I don't attend in the fall yeah
okay I hope it's in the fall and not now
because I wanna keep doing the telling
us you have Collins back but you don't
have Ari's back that's really nice I
think I found out what was happening
first I don't think they've told a lot
of you I don't think a lot of comics
until before they even had the whole
like before I think you guys knew before
they even offered me the hosting job
like I feel like they called the comics
and we're like hey Ari's out oh did they
or did they I don't remember to be
honest with you I I honestly don't
remember but I'm pretty sure that I knew
what was going on before I taped I knew
and I think I'd spoken ari I just don't
remember yeah it was it was it was weird
man and I still hope that the show goes
on I still hope that the show goes on
many many more seasons because it is a
good show and it is unique in the sense
that there's no other stand-up show like
it on tell there's really no there is no
other storytelling show no streaming
service no cable channel has that that
crowd was amazing by the way the place
you chose to shoot it in that strip club
was so good
or whoever chose not I'm sorry there's
always been a strip club for the old the
whole run of the show because like
there's it feels good to be onstage in a
strip club cause you know no matter what
you do up here something worse yeah I'm
that Paul he could see slug trails going
down yes it's not the worst thing that's
happened here dude Howie
they lost his [ __ ] lost his [ __ ] being
around that pole watches said on YouTube
like completely freaked out how is his
story the story was great he's a great
storyteller the story was amazing but
you could tell periodically during his
set he was distracted by this germ field
Pole because you know all of his
germophobia [ __ ] and all that and he
doesn't have money it's just crazy that
he can try to push him into the pole
just try him out of the club he's like
thank you good night literally ran into
a waiting car I would have hated to have
had to follow higher men down that cuz
he is a good storyteller
he's amazing [ __ ] amazing I would not
would have had to run after him did he
just run into a waiting car shake hands
with no one know what he's like that is
what a thank you he was gorgeous yes
sure he about that hanging out is too
many germs in the air [ __ ] I got
a role like Ryan so crazy to not be able
to just go [ __ ] it like I'm gonna take
the germs like it's a taro at a tortured
life that is it's good that he's smart
enough to put business before it like
he's not letting it he will allow
himself to go into that place to do that
show it won't stop him from doing the
show but he's not doing anything beyond
the show in that building I don't think
he knew it was a strip club I think he
just had me hold him my card he how
about court he probably did not hold the
same mic everything else was using no he
held he held the same night I actually
he went in verse he went first he was
the first show first night so I guess he
was technically the first guy on there
but like he legit like his first five
minutes is about the pole it's not even
about the story and I'm sure that's
great yeah he's a funny stamp people for
yet he's been doing this kind of like
you know family-friendly show for a long
time but he was a very very seasoned
comments in the comic does that piss you
off a little bit when you know that
these greats still got it and they just
chill like just I don't want to do that
[ __ ] no more I'm over here like Whoopi
or give me give me Whoopi give me Howie
Mandel drew carey's a very solid comic
drew Tim Allen's a solid comic he's
still kind of goals he stirs to go out
and do it Jim Carrey was a really solid
comedian he's great capito he's not
doing Santa still movies just still like
Bob Saget [ __ ]
and I do like I feel like there's so
many guys from that here's no Bob
actually he just did a special called
zero to sixty Bob actively taught school
he like he's out he's out do we give you
Bob Saget thank you no you can't have
Drew Carey but we'll give you Bob Saget
Farren yes I kiss Aggies at least I'll
perform it like you and he hasn't
stopped these guys just kind of like how
he just comes down from comedy Mountain
delivers a gym and then RIA sins back up
to the top okay I'm gonna do a game show
now well you see with the festivals I
summon my in Montreal like two years ago
he was up there you know he'll go up
there and do like a hosted gala they
probably give him 50 thousand over the
hosted gala who let him do it I mean
whatever you get down from his mountain
right yeah just a mountain have you ever
hosted a gala no I've done one I've done
a few but I've never hosted one do they
pay
I want to see who's hosting you know she
does the three front of 2,000 people
probably good I did it with my Michael
che I'm Colin Jost together we just
figure out what your follow-up question
was for Roy have you ever done a gala
hosted a gala before how much did you
get yeah how much I'm joyous might be
ten thousand you know for I don't know
from Montreal how much we all is cheap
that sounds like a lot of money
nothing well maybe they're just cheap to
me they're black man I'm sure that noise
yeah it is a laser bull why is that that
was an alarm
somebody get beamed up what was that one
did you hear it Travis
you did right what was it well I don't
want to die yeah guys